un spectacle pour annoncer le 92ème
congrès national des enseignants des
écoles et classes maternelles publiques
le rendez vous sont organisés par
l'association agem en juillet 2019 pour
la cinquième fois dans le département
des yvelines
objectif développer des projets sur
l'année pour les tout petits
dans un premier temps ce sont les
enseignants qui réfléchissent en fait
sur la thématique du congrès et cette
thématique en fait est défini en axe de
travail et après les enseignants de
toute la france peuvent s'emparer d'une
des thématiques et travailler dans la
classe avec les élèves
cette année l'événement proposera aux
enfants de travailler sur le thème ozon
les arrêts seront des graines de culture
avec un seul but développer l'éveil des
enfants en maternelle
un projet soutenu par l'éducation
nationale il est clair que ce thème là
est une façon pour les élèves non
seulement de ceux sur de se socialiser
mais aussi d'apprendre et d'apprendre
peut-être par une façon détournée on
comprend très bien qu'avec de jeunes
enfants
on ne peut pas avoir - avec eux qu'avec
d'autres encore une approche académique
des savoirs et ce découverte du monde sa
découverte de l'autre ces découvertes de
la connaissance peut se faire tout à
fait par les arts les enfants
présenteront ensuite leurs travaux
devant plus de 1200 personnes dont des
parents d'élèves et des spécialistes sur
la maternelle l'événement sont
organisées les 3 4 et 5 juillet